today everybody just remind you that we
are here strict oh yeah sorry I gotta do
this first
this is the emergency evacuation I have
to do song should they be required to
evacuate the building you should please
leave the building by the nearest
available exit there's only one fire
exit in your room sorry if you need to
evaluate through and evacuate to be
Valerie evacuate your room please do so
by the glass door external fire exit
please hold both hand raised in case the
rails are wet or slippery if anyone is
done able to use the stairs would they
please allow others to exit the room
before they go to the fire escape door
where they can be given best assistance
I'll say my point will be in the public
car park outside of the Civic suite
please do not to let your evacuation to
collect any belongings please no do not
return to the building until King
permission to do so by counseling staff
can I please come I remind you to switch
off your mobile phone and turned on the
silent
[Music]
[Applause]
right apologies for absence
we have apologies and counselor my own
bed miss tending his none minute said
meeting held in the night 16th of July
are you happy to agree them thank you
declarations of interest are there any
man item six consultation only review of
the statements of the licenses policy
gambling act 2005
good afternoon and objects relax in
London this morning
[Laughter]
and we're looking at our gamble in
policy and just updating it with new
legislation we did do an update last
year quite in-depth update on new
legislation so this is just this week
really just other stuff that's coming up
since we're on that March to you
it has been act consultation and the
consultation is now finished we had two
comments one from Essex Police which
said they had no representations and we
had a letter from gang gang care asking
us to include documents that they had
and look at documents we did actually
look at this last year when we did the
big update last year this was sent to us
last year and we did actually update a
lot of what went on last year we talked
to counselors we obviously came to you
and it was past so I've just looked
through it again just to make sure we've
got everything we do only licensed big
betting offices and betfred
Coral William reads megabit we haven't
got any local and they are they have to
be variable they're very involved with
gang care as well and we see their risk
assessments and we also go out to in
look at them do enforcement and look at
inspections and their licenses with the
Gaming Commission okay so it's gone out
to consultation though the concept over
these rubbings representations we head
back any comments on the representations
just the representation alone any
queries on the policy to this point the
policy has already gone out yes I like
that yeah
I'm sorry we're only here to discuss
[Music]
director sent him better public and the
policy had been agreed so we're not sure
to discuss that so can I ask you please
it's been agreed at the last meeting and
that's not with respect or I say in what
way three is asking for something to do
really in the policy that might be
asking us if we want to retain it yeah
that's that that is part of the yeah
that's part of the recommendations let
them that you're here to richard jeter
me which is basically
my party likes to run referring TVs the
revolvers are six members
recommendations Council devices
authority to resolve or to issue so many
bugs now a six point two to three point
one five it says between they'll get fed
up of people interpreting our politics
in different ways because of the wording
often can be interpreted in different
ways and just because it won't say one
thing in here and people names have you
another way but all these is we're
saying resolve not to issue casino
premises license for the three iteration
of this policy
can we just say for the duration of this
policy they need to review automatically
end of it I'm just a certain appointees
not reviewing for three point five years
then we have issues around it and then
but not come across is what if you talk
now within their policies where this is
a problem because of the one problem a
vibrant I think that just the wording
things the polisseni can be
misinterpreted or because we don't
review it for three years they can get
out of something so you could just
delete three-year no the problem is it's
in the consolation we have to join three
because we won't review business and
policy because we did it last year but
we have to do it every three years and
date is on foreign policy unfortunate I
mean some of them that's fine because
they don't have that particular the
gambling money is in legislation already
care to review as I says we wouldn't
have gone out to review this year really
put the date is on the policy so the
next one will be January 2020 to John we
do you make sure we review these
policies
it has to be so the people didn't run
the person who ran the points not yen
but again it does not have phone calls
University indication
apologies I should have picked up on
that but I presume he doesn't God give
him right anyway you can't get out
without your name that's all part of the
law so although it has a section the
quality of diversity the legislation and
the way these policies are written are
considering Bonneville faithful and
she's what going here are particularly
concerned about and the gambling
Commission
so there are a lot that the betting
shops have to do under their policies
and when we go and expect as well you
know if they find in somebody's betting
too much they will go and speak to them
cash machines can't be too near any
other fixing machines or things like
that so they have to get off a machine
should go and get any money and then
come back there if there is a voluntary
register as well that people can put
their selves on the register and we're
not having betting shops for three
months or but that's a voluntary thing
that they do but that's under the Gaming
Commission and care and the big ones a
bit frayed they all have their own
forces any more questions
can we have some clarity please do you
want to remove two three years or you
want to leave it as it is
I think we can use a clarification does
it all say the Annapolis here we have
the same including the words the
three-year duration of the policy
doesn't say it doesn't say that it just
says the date has to be on it and we had
to look at it every three years on that
day so are we happy it's gonna vote yeah
all in favor
well anybody against leaving it as it is
hanzou all those in favor yeah
anybody against thank you that's courage
I said that's all I know
close the meeting at 10:16 thank you for
coming Cheers